jimi hendrix a mis le feu à la musique
des années 60 et 50 ans après sa mort la
légende est toujours vivant qui est
immortel sa marque a été inégal
il jouait de la guitare avec sa langue
et avec ses dents jimi hendrix s'est
rapidement fait remarquer lors de la
sortie de son premier disque en 1967
c'est d'ailleurs la chanson reprise qui
a poussé steve hill à jouer de la
guitare
c'est ça a changé ma vie complètement
il ya eu le avant la découverte de jimi
hendrix et le après
[Musique]
le génie de jimi hendrix a été de
mélanger avec virtuosité le blues et le
rock avec la musique psychédélique
suprême et on vous dit charles c'est
c'est la même rive que en fait c'est un
dérivé de winston de marijuana
[Musique]
boudou charles michel cusson connaît
aussi la chanson mais ce qu'il
impressionne le plus et l'hymne national
des états unis interprété par hendrix au
festival de woodstock de 1969 et qui
allait devenir un des symboles du
mouvement contre la guerre du vietnam
[Musique]
cinq ans aujourd'hui si c'est un martien
qui fait ça il a aimanté ça spontanément
comme ça c'est épouvantable
moi ça me jette à terre encore
[Musique]
après avoir réalisé trois albums studio
et un album en concert
jimi hendrix est décédée à l'âge de 27
ans d'une surdose de somnifères
le guitariste nous a quittés au sommet
de son art lui c'est vraiment la
référence à dieu compartiment des ventes
est que si tu me lis encore aujourd'hui
vous pensé à tout et je finis mon show
avec vos dit charles je faisais ce que
je fais et je suis encore c'est trente
ans plus tard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici louis fait depuis mai radio-canada
moria bon les voisins doivent être tanné